remember when i was in college and i was
doing some uh
i took acting one and acting two
and i had to uh memorize
all of the lines uh and i
thought that perhaps by this time i
i should have the chairman script
memorized but
i don't so i will read
i will read the script
as chairman of division two of the house
finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically this public meeting
is pertaining to the department of
transportation
and any other issues that we might be
able
to conduct dealing with either hb1
or hb2 please note
that there is no fiscal location for
members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
however in accordance with emergence the
emergency order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in
this meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar
on the general court website the notice
for this meeting complies with house
rules
and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should email lba underscore
at leg dot state dot nh
dot u s in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
the lba staff are on the meeting
assisting us
please note that all votes that are
taken during the meeting shall be done
by roll call
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required
under the right to know law
representative lin
if you would please call the role yes so
thank you madam chair um
i understand that representative porter
is
substituting for representative bucco so
i'm here thank you i'm sorry thank you
thank you
and uh next i understand that
representative turcotte is
uh substituting for representative
danielson representative lynn
excuse me uh representative porter did
not state where she was
oh i'm sorry i apologize i'm at home in
my office
alone but my husband is in the house
thank you representative turca
yes i'm at my home i'm here and my wife
will be
passing through in about an hour thank
you
representative heath hi mary heath here
in manchester
in my home and currently i am home alone
but i expect my husband and my
two grandsons will be coming in pretty
soon thank you
hi i'm bob lynn i'm president of my home
in windham
my wife is in the house but not in this
room
um representative murray good morning
i'm kate murray in newcastle with my dog
david is not in the basement let me say
that he
he and my son and his family have headed
off to dave borden's farm to witness
sugaring
old-fashioned sugaring terrific
uh representative petrie right
representative petry here in farmington
uh
just have the dog today thank you
and representative umberger thank you
i'm in my home in curse kearsarge and my
husband
is uh in the house
obviously not real interested in what
we're doing
but he is here so
okay okay thank you you're quite welcome
um i'd like to uh welcome our folks from
dot and um
i'm not sure who wants to speak first
but um i think that uh
we have some things to go over
and um i'd like it looks like uh
commissioner sheehan has unmuted so
if you would we'd appreciate it so good
morning madam chair members of the
committee
and for the new members i just want to
introduce the dot
team briefly um so participating today
is myself
commissioner victoria sheehan we also
have our assistant commissioner bill
cass available for questions
chris wozchuk our deputy commissioner
marie mullen our director of finance
and um also participating today are
patrick harlehe
our director of aeronautics rail and
transit
um and kathy mckay hamson who is our
legislative liaison there may be other
dot
folks joining us as we progress through
the meeting
um and deal with the different areas
within our budget
so with that madam chair i'm not sure uh
what materials you were hoping to cover
today my understanding was you wanted to
go through the budget
page by page so we're ready and willing
to do that anytime
okay that sounds perfect
um does anyone have
representative heath thank you madam
chair
and um thank you all for being here i
just it's so
fascinating everything that that comes
out of your department
um i see that we have somebody here from
aeronautics
and um the first section of our budget
um kind of relates to that
could you just kind of talk a little bit
about what's going on what's new
um some of the things you're asking for
uh
what's happened over the last biennium
you want me to handle that commissioner
i think that's appropriate
um the depart the bureau of the division
of aeronautics rail and transit and
specific the bureau of aeronautics
oversees approximately 20 million
dollars a year in federal funding
through the airport improvement program
that funding actually goes through the
capital budget
as opposed to the operating budget and
is matched by the state
it's a it's a 9010 program it's matched
by the state
um five percent and by the airports five
percent
um there are 12 eligible federally
federally eligible airports
in the state three three commercial
airports
which are of course manchester lebanon
and pease
and then there are nine general aviation
airports nashua being the largest
uh that are eligible for that funding
but we also have
funding available through the airway
toll which is also in the budget as a
separate org code
the airway toll funding is about 225 000
a year that funding primarily and
priority wise goes to the non-federal
airports the smaller uh airports that
are
that may be privately owned but they're
open to the public
uh none of the funding goes to privately
owned that aren't open to the public
um so that that funding has been very
successful we just
uh went through governor and council to
approve um
re rehabbing the jaffrey airport
uh runway which hadn't been done since
1961 and was in very
dire need of being done for safety
reasons so that that airway toll fund
has been
um very significant for those airports
that
cannot realize federal funding uh the
other big thing we're looking at
in the office in in the bureau of
aeronautics are uh
unmanned aerial systems or drones
and and in fact there's a position in
the budget that was granted two years
ago and it was carried forward by the
governor this year to have a position
to look at and to work with unmanned
aircraft systems both
uh from for private industries that are
using them but as well as the department
that
uh is looking at using them for a myriad
of things
uh to do with with the construction
projects and inspection projects
uh the bureau of aeronautics also um
inspects
all of the public uh open to the public
airports each year to make sure they're
that they're safe and
and they're compliant with faa
guidelines and we also
administer the aircraft registration
program uh so each
aircraft owner in the state of new
hampshire or who has a plane base in the
state of new hampshire
is required to pay an aircraft
registration fee
250 000 of that registration fee goes
back
to those airports based on the number of
based aircraft in each of the
at each of those airports and then the
remaining balance goes into the general
fund
um so that's that's pretty much it in a
nutshell in case
unless there's any other specific
questions you'd like to ask on that
um just um on page 851
the equipment line and i know this is
all federal funds
um i see that you have a big decrease
um in the the pending um biennium
where you've gone from almost 4 million
4.1 million and 1.3
down to 870 000 um and then 340 000.
is that a decline in funding or what is
um that has to do with the um
the the state bus program so we needed
this
one yeah oh okay all right thank you
yeah that was
that big increase when we we did a
replacement program for the 22 bus and
express
24 bus and express buses that we own but
that the replacement program will be
completed before the next biennium
okay thank you very much and if i could
just follow up madam chair
absolutely um could you just um
buses have taken a big hit during the
pandemic
um and i'm sure you have um
what what does it look like is it
starting to come back
or what do you anticipate it's starting
to come back but it's very slowly
coming back on the local public transit
side they're about at 50 percent
ridership
then pre-pandemic levels uh the inner
city bus
industry though is is in the commuter
bus
industry in particular is has not come
back yet
um ridership is
almost 90 percent less than what it was
but pre-pandemic
but it is it's part of our
infrastructure and luckily we
on the boston express side we'll be able
to realize cares act funding
uh to keep those buses going um because
at some point the commuter market is
going to come back uh we don't know to
what degree yet
but we need to be ready for when that
when that does happen
thank you very much are there
any other questions from the committee
oh good good he's a really nice guy
okay uh seeing none uh mr hurley i
i do have a couple of questions
um in your
general fund area is that
all for airports
the general fund area for us is all in
uh staffing and administrative costs in
in
the in aeronautics and 2107 and in
the uh rail and transit is for rail
staff
for for rail staffing and for half of
the administrator's salary
for the rail and transit bureau the
administrator gets paid half federal and
half general funds representative
umberger there's also two hundred
thousand dollars
each year in the transit bureau of
general funds
to assist the the locals with their
match
um against the federal program that was
um included in the budget last year
um and had the governor has continued
that uh in our budget this year as well
yeah the fed the federal funding for for
local transit agencies
isn't uh for operating as a 50 50
program
so 50 comes from the feds and 50 comes
from either local or state resources
and the 200 000 goes towards that 50
is that sufficient to cover the match
or uh do the local communities
need to pony up the local communities
pony up in a
and what communities are we talking
about
uh wherever the public wherever local
public transit system so it's both rural
communities and urban communities
so the urban systems run on the seacoast
in manchester
in nashua and um at unh
and the rural community the rurals come
from the north country
north country transit carroll county
transit
even concord area transit is considered
a rural service
uh sullivan county i mean they're they
they cover the state
for the most part so any any um
community that they operate in
is asked to provide part of that local
match
okay that's i just
i i thought that's what it was but i
wanted to uh
i wanted to uh be sure um
so your your general funding you said
covers
mostly salaries is that and
mostly mostly what's in um org code 2107
so anything that's in 2107 which is
aeronautics
all of that is general fun
except for the air well the airway tolls
it's on separate
and then what's in um
2931 railroad that cover that so that
and then as marie mentioned the 200 000
that goes towards the local transit
match and half the salary and benefits
for the
okay and there have been no personnel
increases or anything like that in
either of those
divisions um for this
proposed biennium yes no there was a
transfer of a highway funded position
um from highway design into rail and
transit because that person works on
but that's highway funded okay so
that person is considered highway funded
correct
okay
staffing
okay are there
yes representative heath thank you madam
chair
um last session we spent a lot of time
talking about rail um and
what was happening with rail could you
just update i see
that um that it's pretty
consistent um in the general fund uh
for uh that line can you just update us
on how that's going and um
what the plan is anything input for
anything in particular or
the at the uh real
transportation to boston from manchester
uh the capital corridor project yes
yes the cap the capital pride capital
corridor project we are currently in the
project development phase for that
so we did a study back in 2014
which looked at alternatives to to get
to boston
um the alternative of the of a
manchester regional service
with two stops in manchester two stops
to nashua
uh to go on to the one at manchester
airport
to go to boston um that is a federally
funded
project the pro that we're working on
the project development phase includes
the engineering
uh to come up with a cost a realistic
and final cost estimate that we need to
carry forward for the rest of the
project
to do the environmental uh review that's
necessary
and most importantly to come up with a
financial plan on how
this is going to get paid for how the
capital that
the non-federal capital share will be
paid for as well as the operating costs
going forward
so we just kicked that project off a
couple months ago we fired a consultant
a
ecom this is a national consultant to
help with that
we have met with our federal partners at
the federal transit administration
we've also met with massdot and mbta
just to kick this off and now we're
looking at trying to schedule meetings
with stakeholders
that that we need to to help us with
station design
station location as well as the
financial plan
oh yes representative maria question
thank you very much uh if we can just go
back
a stat on 854 page 854
sorry um i assume on line 30 there's the
50 000
is that par these are two questions is
that part of the bus replacement
um or other sorts of replacement and
then what happened
in on line 46 so you have almost three
million dollars
adjusted authorized um
actual expense was nothing it's three
hundred thousand just what's the story
behind that
uh representative murray could you tell
me what page that was on
or with page eight five four
and i was particularly looking line 30
and 43 you know the consultants that
apparently were never used and they're
gone now and
um just the narrative behind that please
uh representative murray the
the consultant line that is for the
capital corridor and
we have gone to gnc so those funds are
encumbered and will be utilized
that's why you see the the decrease in
the out years um
because that contract has been um
uh contracted um and the equipment in
class 30
that can vary that's um uh you know
equipment for um that they that is
purchased with federal funds for
various um operations at the bus
stations
um outside of the the boston express so
um that can vary from year to year in
the program
yeah and that 50 000 in fy 20
was primarily for camera replacement
security camera replacements at the bus
facilities that we own thank you so much
i'm so happy to hear about the capital
corridor
you're welcome
on aeronautics and rail
i have trouble trying to keep my fingers
on
what i need to talk about
um
okay
representative umberger yes just real
quick i i just want to let
representative uh
turcon represent porter know that i did
email them links to the
the governor's budget document that we
are working through now it just dawned
on me they don't have hard copies at
home yet so
um just in case they're following along
check your email you can find the link
to what we're working through
thank you mickey i
um dave rodriguez on the line i just
wanted to let you know so you could
elevate him for
okay um is anyone else have any
questions
this is dealing with the office of
federal compliance
and i noticed that in the last
two years there was nothing funded in
that
area but yet we are
um putting in additional
what appears to be additional money in
and 23 or was that just
um just the way it was
uh representative umberger in that
accounting unit
it did exist um previously we had it as
a hundred percent highway funds
and as we evaluated you know their
functions we
determined that they really should be a
hundred percent federal funds
so you you see there that the the
funding was actually switched from
100 percent highway funds to 100 federal
funds
but that their budget overall budget has
not
increased from fy 2021 it's actually
um down slightly in both years
just explain what the role of the office
of federal compliance is
because we are a federally funded agency
we are required to
follow all federal guidelines across our
programs whether they're funded
directly with federal dollars or not and
so that's why previously
because they supported the entire
department we didn't show them as
a federally funded office within d.o.t
but at the end of the day we're required
to have these programs because we
receive federal funds and so that's why
we're making the switch
it's a more appropriate way to fund this
particular office
but they will continue to support the
entire department
if i may on the previous page 868 shows
all the line items
for the uh for that office so you can
see there's
actually been some reductions that has
been renoted in 22 from 20
representative murray thank you madam
chair
um apropos it's someone you just said of
i see there are six positions in this
the office of federal compliance
you said they're also supporting um the
rest of transportation
so do they deal with compliance issues
that are not federally related as well
um so they're housed here but they also
do other work
their full-time isn't just federal
compliance it's also other
aspects of your your organization it is
full-time federal compliance um but the
federal
codes um require us to not just follow
federal guidelines on our federally
funded programs
so because we are receiving federal
funds as an agency as an example
we have to be an equal opportunity
employer
and so it doesn't matter whether we're
hiring for operation maintenance
which isn't federally funded or whether
we're hiring for those bureaus that
receive federal dollars
we still have to ensure that we are
following um all the criteria
around how we post and recruit for our
own
internal workforce and so that's
what i mean when i say they support the
entire department um it's not just
our bureaus and sections that are funded
directly with federal funds
yes thank you madam chair the
in federal tax monies or whatever
how much do we get back percentage-wise
back to the state are you referring to
our federal gas tax
contributions representative petersburg
yes and any other
taxes that they may collect uh you know
for that purpose
for you know for highway um so
by law um where our federal gas tax
contributions are concerned
and we're required to get at least 95
back
um new hampshire actually gets about 116
it varies um slightly year to year
um but that is based on and the fact
that
the federal um highway trust fund
has been insolvent and there's been a
general fund infusion
to fund all the federal programs and so
that is why um we get slightly more than
what we pay in
and but we still get less federal money
than many other states
um of similar size uh to new hampshire
as an example we always um point out
that the
the folks in vermont receive around 300
of their
federal gas tax contributions um despite
the fact
they have less miles of national highway
system and a
smaller population in new hampshire
follow-up yes please go ahead
right and the
the amount of monies that it costs
to implement these federal programs
uh in other words the more we
uh how much does it cost to
implement these federal programs i mean
you know versus if we
kept the money you know without a gas
so a lot of the work that they're
funding is you know designing
construction efforts
and so yes there's an administrative
burden of following all of the federal
requirements um but many of those
requirements
are actually um you know complementary
of what we have in state law
in terms of ensuring you know
competitive procurement opportunities
um and items like that there are certain
federal requirements which are
more cumbersome but i struggled to
articulate exactly what that
difference in cost would be between
administering
projects under state law versus federal
law
sometimes it's more delay just working
through
for example environmental permitting
processes and things like that can take
time
and certainly when we have to have
documents
reviewed and approved by federal
agencies
you know that can be cumbersome
but as i said you know a lot of the
other aspects of administering these
programs are
are similar whether we're following
federal guidance or state
thank you representative porter you have
your hand raised
yes madam chair i just wanted to let you
know my husband is now in the room with
me
along with one of our cats okay
let's do cat all right
okay um i would like to
thank you madam chair i just wanted to
move to um the highway
maintenance is it okay to move ahead
yes absolutely
and it's way at the bottom and it's
federal
revenue experts from other oh transfers
there um and then we've got the line
that says federal funds and i think i
know the answer to this
the 41. page uh i'm sorry the page is
876.
um commissioner is that the infusion
that you have from um the cares act
on that line under 2022
where it says federal funds it's all
zero except that one spot and then
it's lists the highway funds and then my
second question is
are you seeing a return to a more
healthy
um so i'll let marie take the first
question and i'll take the second so
i'll start with that response
um you know we have been working very
closely with our colleagues at the
department of safety
um as we try to forecast revenues
and we discussed this at some of the
last work sessions
um we're still not seeing traffic
volumes returned to
pre-covert levels um you know on more
rural roadways
traffic volumes are down to a lesser
degree
but on our you know high volume
facilities because of the reduction in
commuter traffic
and we're still seeing um less
significantly less cars on the road
and so it does depend on the car door um
now if you know if you're watching the
revenue focus you'll see that in areas
like registration fees there's been
a little bit of a bump um but overall
no we're not seeing the highway fund
return to pre-covert levels
and then as we explained during our last
work session you know
further as we look to the future the
increase in fuel efficiency of vehicles
um is still something that we have to
pay close attention to
so it'll be a challenging time for all
of us
in terms of projecting revenues um we're
watching what's happening in other parts
of the country
for the turnpike um we have a consulting
firm
that assists us in forecasting uh first
the traffic
um and then the associated revenue and
you know we're partnering with safety
and trying to provide them with as much
information as possible
since they're the ones that collect the
revenue to support them
as they're presenting to ways and means
and working with the governor's office
and revenue thank you
do you want to answer the other question
yeah so the the 41 million dollars uh
you're correct
representative heath that is um it's
related to the
um coronavirus relief act that was
enacted at the end of december so it's
different than the cares act
um it's this the subsequent one that was
at the end of signed into law at the end
of december
and so dots were provided direct funding
in that bill
and the state of new hampshire dot was
provided 41 million dollars so
that is where we have placed those funds
in the budget
to be utilized and as you can see it
displaced the highway funds for that
fiscal year
thank you that was going to be my next
question thank you you're welcome
and uh if i could follow up on that
uh marie are we anticipating
getting any uh funds out of the new
act that will be signed tomorrow that
can be used
with the highway fund um there
there aren't any direct funds to the
highway fund in that bill there are some
funds for aeronautics and and transit
that are direct but not to the highway
and state dots
the state will be receiving and the
commissioner can probably expound on
this more the state will be receiving a
portion
of the 350 billion going to state and
local government
of that portion that the state dot may
receive
you know we don't know at this time but
the commissioner
you know may want to add something to
that
um so marie is correct there's no direct
assistance
for lost highway related revenues
um we you know continue to advocate at
the federal level
um that we have seen significant
reductions
um both on our federal aid system and
but also on the turnpike system
and so um we will be working with the
governor's office and trying to learn
more about what the opportunities might
be
with the assistance that was provided
for state and local governments
i know that there are some
municipalities that would
hope to use some of those relief dollars
for transportation purposes perhaps
but it's very early to we haven't even
seen the guidance yet um
in terms of how those dollars can be
used other than the bill text
and then um now that the relief bill has
moved forward for the president's
signature we expect congress in short
order to start talking about an
infrastructure package
and that might be where there's more
opportunity
to advocate for highway investments
not just capital projects on the
national highway system but perhaps some
assistance for projects
on the non-federal aid system and so we
will continue to advocate
in the weeks and months ahead that we
there's going to be federal funding for
infrastructure that that be as flexible
um a package as possible so that we
could really try and
um ensure that we're you know assisting
with addressing this lost revenue
across our entire network not just on
the assets that would typically be
are there any other questions on this
issue
representative heath oh thank you madam
chair i'm on
looking at um this continues to be
about um oh i'm sorry i'm actually
jumping to bridge maintenance
is that all right on page 878
of course that's fine um
on underneath estimated source of funds
for bridge maintenance bureau
you have um projected the
highway funds for 2022 8.4
and then for um 23 8.8
now is that a high estimate uh
for those lines i'm just
based on what you've said about the
highway funds um
i'm fearful that that
won't be a reality and if that isn't a
reality
what does that mean so representative
heath
we've worked very closely with the
department of safety you know we're
confident that um
the revenue projections have been put
forward are
realistic and so this is a balanced
budget um
based on the current revenue projections
uh this work
would be funded i also want to
acknowledge that dave rodrigue our
director of operations
um has joined the call and so if you do
have specific questions on the work of
our
operations bureaus he is available as
well
thank you representative murray
thank you madam chair uh same page
that's where i was headed but a little
bit further up
the 1.7 million that was in 2021 i guess
that was not expended
uh can you tell me the story about where
that went
uh it says is that operational services
and just you know what that means
um what it means in the paper but also
what it means in real life
and there's the two million or one and a
half million
drop in your total budget for that
pardon me um is that going to impact
your ability to continue to do
so this funding was a new program in the
um fiscal year 2021 program it was for
bridge washing
that was to be able to um wash some of
our tier
tier one high volume bridges um
every year instead of every other year
they cove it in the revenue
shortfalls this program was
eliminated in fy 20 and 21 to
to you know assure we had sufficient
funds to maintain
you know the system and it was also cut
in our 2223 budget to be able to balance
um based on the reduced revenue
projections
yes absolutely is that a is this a
covert related fatality or is this
something that's more
inherent in what transportation is
dealing with
so representative murray um i'm really
for the benefit
of the new committee members today um
you know as marie said this was a new
program so given the help of the highway
fund and then how significantly
cloven 19 impacted our revenues there
was several items that we put on hold
last year that we could lapse additional
dollars
and then in this budget um as marie
explained because of the health of the
highway fund we're not moving forward
um so it's not just uh this particular
item around bridge washing
um for the the new members today
you know we've other programs such as
guardrail repair and graffiti removal
that were funded in the last budget and
we did not move forward and expand those
dollars because of
covet 19 and then we have not included
those items in this budget
because of the ongoing concerns about
the health of the highway fund
thank you so if i might
follow up on that so the drop from
10 million to 8 million that is
in all brick bridge washing guard rails
or is that just in the bridge washing
area this is
the bridge maintenance bureau so this is
just the reduction in
the bridge washing but as you go through
the other
bureau's budget you'll see similar
changes
okay okay so we're not eliminating the
bridge washing program or the others
we're just cutting back on how much
we're doing is that
what i'm hearing correct ideally we'd
wash our bridges you know every spring
after the winter season to wash away all
the salt um
these additional dollars would allow us
to do that instead we're going back to
every other year
essentially all right thank you thank
you
uh representative petrie have a question
yes uh thank you
uh on the uh 20 match
do you feel confident that you'll be
able to meet the 20
you talk about the 20 match you mean our
20 match to federal
projects or are you talking about the uh
no the low
one when the uh when a low
uh matter of fact municipality like
farmington uh we have several
redless bridges and if we decide to
uh build those will the 20 be there
that uh for the match
so the municipality provides the twenty
percent match
we progress i'm sorry but if
if the twenty if you if they put up to
20 percent
is the money there for the rest of the
bills
so i think we touched on this last
session i apologize i don't have the
chart in front of me
um but the we are very confident
um that we have adequate revenue um
in the short term to proceed with all of
the
bridge projects that are programmed in
state a bridge program um i think what
you're referring to
is over time
the revenue projections um as well as
the principal payments kicking in on the
tiffy alone
mean that there is concern about the
amount of dollars available for
the city bridge program but for this
budget we are very confident that we
have
adequate funding um and that's something
that we'll look at more closely you know
it's
um it's a concern into the out years but
we need to continue to monitor the
revenues and
adjust the projections accordingly thank
you
representative i do thank you madam
chair
uh good morning commissioner sheehan uh
i guess the question be for you
you you mentioned something near and
dear to me uh graffiti removal
um do you i know it's not a single line
item but
do you have a number for say the last
year on
a dollar amount on how much was spent on
graffiti removal
and then um if possible if i could
get a number on say five years ago what
that number was
i'm just seeing a huge increase
everywhere i drive and it drives me up a
wall
seeing it i just would like to know uh
you know how much we're actually
spending on that thank you
so i'm not sure if any of us have
those numbers at hand today um certainly
my colleagues can chime in if they do
i will tell you representative um
unfortunately
with the health of the highway fund and
the concerns um
around available revenue we really have
cut back to focus on
our core maintenance of the system and
in particular you know
public safety and operationally making
sure that we're addressing issues
so unfortunately some of the more
cosmetic things um
as important as they are in terms of
setting the right
or first impression for visitors who
come to the state and for others
that's the type of work that we have
been forced to defer
um so i i'll um
happily uh get that information for you
what's been spent in the past
and um what we've been spending most
recently
thank you that that'd be very helpful
okay are there other questions
okay i i would like to if i
figure out what were what we're going to
do
i i see that if i am
understanding correctly uh you have
um increased the winter maintenance by
um four million dollars
and i know in the past we generally have
not
funded um winter maintenance
at 100 level and
um i was wondering where
uh we stood on that
and whether or not
we can reduce winter maintenance
costs at this point knowing that
as time goes by if
indeed you need to come to fiscal uh
that that's
appropriate so
i'll start and let marie or others chime
in um
so when we were working on the budget in
the governor's face
we anticipated um having to come back to
fiscal this year
to ask for additional dollars for winter
maintenance
fortunately and the last couple of weeks
have been milder
than we had anticipated and so we've
been looking at what our needs are
between now and the end of the winter
season and so
we are going to be moving forward with a
fiscal item on the next
meeting agenda but the ask is much
smaller so
um that means there'll be additional
dollars available
to help address some of these highway
fund
issues and then with respect to the
upcoming
um budget you know we were very pleased
that
in the governor's phase um we were
funded for
an average winter whereas typically we
have been
funded at a lower level and then as you
explained
madam chair we have to go to fiscal and
ask for additional dollars
um my understanding is the revenue
projections from house ways and means
for the highway fund are a little bit
lower than in the governor's phase
and so um certainly if you're looking
for areas to cut from
um we've explained how lean we are in
other areas of the department
um it would be appropriate to reduce the
amount that's been budgeted for winter
once again
with the understanding that if we had an
average winter or worse
we would go to the fiscal committee and
request those additional dollars at that
time
um so i know that marie had a
conversation with steve lavoy from
safety and with mickey so i'll let her
talk about the specific dollar values
that we
are thinking um but yes certainly
our preference would be that if you're
trying to
reduce certain items based on revised
revenue
projections that we would um
rather than have unnecessary cuts from
other areas of dot
and then up then end up having a mild
winter not using all of those winter
maintenance dollars
um it makes a lot of sense to do what
the legislature has done in the past
reduce the value of those lines hope
that mother nature is kind to us
um and then if she's not we'll go to
marie would you go ahead please sure
so um for fy 21
in the governor's phase for in the
projection
in the surplus statement we had
projected
needing approximately nine million
dollars uh for
additional for winter um as the
commissioner stated
it's been a little milder recently we've
we've taken a look at the numbers
and we feel we'll only need about 5
million of that 9 million dollars so
therefore an additional 4 million would
be able to go towards the highway fund
deficit towards those revenue reductions
um and then um i know based on the the
revenue changes there will be some
changes to block grant
um and so whatever the net
cha difference is that's needed in the
highway fund i'm sure mickey
um is calculating that um you know that
that amount what if it's a million a
million and a half
2 million whatever that might be we
would
you know be willing to reduce our class
20 line
equally over fy 22 and 23
to be able to have the highway fund
balance at the end of the biennium
okay uh mickey have
have you looked at the block grant
numbers
i have and i i mailed those out emailed
those out to everybody last night
so based on based on uh the
house estimates versus the governor's
estimates um i think block grant
just because that is a statutory formula
based on
revenues uh certain road toll and motor
vehicle fee revenues
um a budget adjustment of about four
hundred thousand dollars
net over the two years um would probably
be
uh prudent to make um and it's
uh customary that's what we do at each
phase in the budget we'll line up
block grant sb 367 account as well as
betterment to align with the
road toll and motor vehicle fee
estimates so based on what marie
and the commissioner were saying about
winter maintenance for this year
the reduction from 9 million to 5
as far as the need to close out fiscal
also making that adjustment to the block
grant appropriation leaves about a
million and a half
over the biennium to get the highway
fund
into the black so to speak so to do what
marie was discussing
to do equally over the two years in
winter maintenance class 20
a 750 000 a year reduction of that line
would have a balanced highway fund
okay thank you thank you marie thank you
commissioner sheehan uh representative
yes madam chair this is a real newbie
question
so i'm listening to this and i'm trying
to understand how this process works
the department comes in and asks us for
make up a number a thousand dollars to
take care of the roads for the winter
in an average an average cost would be a
thousand dollars
we come back to them and say we'll only
give you eight hundred dollars
if you need more come to fiscal is that
how it works
that's exactly how it works and can i
ask another question
that's how it works as long as there's
money in the highway fund
can i ask yeah can i ask another
question then what happens if there's no
money in fiscal for
how do we pay for maintaining the roads
that heavy winter that we weren't
expecting because
um i think we'd flip a coin but mickey
maybe you could give us a better answer
than that
it is a newbie question i i apologize
for my ignorance
i i mean fiscal has the authority to uh
although i can't recall it happening
anytime in the last decade or so to
approve an item that is projected to
send the highway fund into a deficit if
if they so chose to do that
obviously uh at any point in time that
the department or
you know comes forward with a request to
draw from highway surplus
we're projecting that fund balance as of
that point so for instance we're coming
in
this next fiscal committee meeting with
a request and we're projecting out
fiscal 21's balance as of march
um it is it is up to the fiscal
committee should they want to
approve an item if the outlook was a
negative situation
um ideally we wouldn't be in that
situation but i think it's
thank you we do not play shell games
okay
that's
i think that that that's where we stand
on that but
uh fortunately in the past the highway
fund has
always been able to absorb
this now listening to
or looking at the the projections
for 22 and 23 for the highway fund
we may run into some problems
but all i can do is ask you to drive
and make sure you spend some time on the
turnpikes as well okay
unfortunately my new car is a hybrid so
even if i drive more it's not going to
help much but
um are there any other questions
that folks have
[Applause]
let me continue flipping through my
pages here
but i think i have one but you might get
to me you might already
be there go ahead the reps of murray
can you just speak to what reimbursable
maintenance and repairs
um it you know there's not a lot of
change in there
but just um what that's going to how
that's going to look out for the next
couple years
thank you yeah these
this is a an area where
we have our guard rail repairs so when
folks hit and damage our guard rail we
have a claims process
those expenditures come through here if
we have any
major fema events you know
major winter storms flooding those type
of things
those things would go through here and
we would receive
revenue for those type of things so
they're more for like emergency
and damages that we'll get reimbursed
for
in the past we've had you know bridge
hits down
at the seacoast we've had you know we've
had a ship hit a bridge
um i remember that we were reimbursed by
insurance and those
costs go through here um so it's just an
availability for emergencies so we can
quickly respond and
make the repairs that are needed so this
changes this can change considerably
from year to year
um i don't suppose there's anything
really
any covet funds that would be related to
anything around here because there are
some fema funds but it would not
none of that would affect would pertain
um well there are areas but they
probably wouldn't go through this
accounting unit
um a lot of the covid related items are
personnel costs
related to folks working at the call
centers and that type of thing so
they're not necessarily related to
construction um and repair type
type items so thank you yeah
uh representative murray uh we we also
have an hb2 item
dealing with this uh on the uh
insurance payback of insurance so that
will be
uh um we'll discuss that when
okay let's go ahead represent a piece oh
thank you madam chair
um i'm gonna jump ahead to page eight
eight eight
if that's okay um we're
about over weight permits
um and under agency income
it's got um for
20 20 20 20 22
255.5 and for 23
uh for 19.1 is that
an anticipated increase based on
when things come back to normal because
i noticed in um
21 it was uh 392.3
so it it looks like is is that the
reason
there's there's some um there can be
some
additional revenue in that area so we
basically will budget
for the expenditures in that year um
but when we get into fy23 you can see
there's an addition of some highway
funds in there
beginning in fy 23 we have a new
oversized overweight system
and the annual maintenance and hosting
costs
come into play and we have to start
paying
that portion out of the oversize and
overweight permits so it
it that is bringing us over the amount
of revenue
uh we our expenditures will be over the
amount of revenue that we generally
collect
in that accounting unit so that's the
reason for that
that increase there you may see in fy 22
you may see some
additional revenue there but it's hard
to
to to gauge and we we do try to reflect
what we
anticipate for expenditures and
generally any
revenue that comes in over our
expenditures lapses
into the highway fund thank you and then
i'm chair by may
certainly um marie
as we look at the volume
in especially southern new hampshire and
the seacoast
the volume of of trek seems to be
increasing
um by quite a bit do you have any
numbers or figures about an increase in
that
and and its relation to revenue for the
state of new hampshire i mean is that a
good thing or
do you does the department overall
suffer do the roads suffer from the
volume of
um increased those uh truckloads that
um go across our roads i
i would defer to dave i don't know if he
has the information
um on the number of trucks and the
increase in volume
we can get that for you but i defer to
dave rodrigue our director of operations
to see if he has
any of that information available thank
you
thank you marie and thank you for the
question representative heath
i do not have um information
on the increase in truck traffic
as a percentage of our regular traffic
volume
but what i can tell you is that trucks
impact and degrade our roadways
significantly more for for viet than
regular passenger cars in the weight
of the trucks on the roadways has a
significant event
or it has a significant increase in the
damage
so what we always say is
trucks increase the damage exponentially
as the weight increases and it's
actually
exponentially to the fourth power
so what may seem like a very small
increase
in weight of the overall vehicle or even
more
specifically the axle weight of the
vehicle
well it may seem like a relatively small
increase in the weight the amount of
damage that it does to the roadway
for let's say a 38 000 pound
axle load to a 40 000 pound axle load
the amount of damage for that change is
actually one and a half times the
the damage so as we get heavier
and heavier trucks on the road and
heavier
and heavier axle loads the amount of
damage we do
thank you um it may i may madam chair
just to follow up quickly on that
problem um in relation to that um
that seems to make a lot of sense
because those trucks are getting bigger
it seems
um the costs that
you have revenue coming in with the
permits
but the costs to the damage to our roads
do they balance out or is does that
create more problems for you
so representative if i may this is the
oversized overweight program
individuals only need a permit when they
are carrying a load that exceeds the
statutory limits
and so many of the trucks you see on the
road don't require these permits
um yes they're large vehicles they're
heavy vehicles
and but their registration and other
fees are based on the weight
and so they are paying more for use of
the system
it's only if they exceed those statutory
load limits
um then they or they have an oversized
vehicle
then they have to apply for a permit um
and that's for everyone's safety we want
to make sure the route that they're
driving
the infrastructure can handle both the
size and the weight of the vehicles that
would be on the road
thank you so it's it's not just this one
area that's
um that the trucks are
contributing to um they're paying the
other
highway fund revenue as well
as contributing to this particular line
item
okay could we go back just a minute to
page 886
is this a result of road salt
so yes you're correct this is to do with
road salt um since we have dave i'll let
him explain the
program but we have many items that go
before governor and council associated
with
our uh assault impacts to wells
so thank you madam chair for the for the
question
what what this is a a program that
the department is statutorily required
um to investigate and
under certain circumstances replace
wells that have been compromised um
by salt primarily due to
um salt use for de-icing so i don't have
the
the rsa in front of me that describes a
program
but the rough variables are there was a
a point in time around um
the mid to late 1960s i believe
that if a a well was more
than a certain distance from the road i
think
it's 75 feet and it was in place
before um 1960 something
if it becomes contaminated with salt the
department will pay
for the cost of the replacement for the
well
and in order that there's a process in
place where
the water is sampled over a six to 12
month
period on the salt has to show up at a
certain concentration
at each test um the topography
and everything has to make sense for the
contamination
to come from a a state source not a
local or municipal source
and if all those things come together
the department will replace a well
for the for an individual if it's
contaminated
by us do we have any idea
how many wells fall into this 75-foot
category
across the state or is this just
the the way the program works we receive
a complaint from an individual
and then we we open up the investigation
um we tend to to replace about
three or four wells uh a year
um so on average sometimes
uh a little bit higher than that um
and if you'd like i can provide you the
the statute that describes the program
um and what we work and well that that's
fine i just wanted to
um know if we had any kind of projection
uh for the future of this program and it
the other thing i would add it has been
fairly consistent as dave said the
average of um you know three to four
um wells a year so uh you know at least
well we don't have the projection at
least monitoring the activity and stuff
if it was creeping up or anything we
would be able to
react and adjust to that the only other
thing i would just note it is specific
to
residential wells it doesn't cover
businesses or or municipal
wells so it's very specific to those
private residential properties
thank you um representative porter you
have a question
it's not a question madam chair and
being a pest again i'm going to need to
leave the
meeting in about 10 minutes no problem
thank you we're glad you were able to
okay are there other questions from
anybody
okay let's go to my favorite topic
okay okay um a page number
uh we're on page 889
how many lift bridges do we still have
do you want me to answer that i think we
have three
correct we have three glyph
madam chair we have three lift bridges
that are regularly
operated two in portsmouth the memorial
and
and sarah longbridge we have the hampton
river bridge
that is operated regularly during the
summer season
and on call during the winter season
and we have one other um
lift bridge that is operated
representative murray is very familiar
with that one the newcastle rye
i was just saying i told my grandson
that that bridge is going to be replaced
and he was just heartbroken
and he says he wants us to still be a
singing bridge i think i don't know
about that london
so i'm you know to follow up actually
potentially
um two of these bridges will be going
away
the hampton bridge and the new castle
bridge although the
final the decisions are not there yet
but when you're talking about this can
you talk about the impact of not having
so as dave indicated the newcastle rye
bridge
you know may only be opened once a year
so that's a minimal impact
um if the hampton harbor bridge
was to be replaced with a fixed
structure and then yes we would be
consolidating our operations we'd only
be responsible for the memorial on the
is there a projection as to when the
bill would you like to provide an update
on the schedule for that
project yes i know where i'm getting
ready to take the uh
zebra hampton project to a a public
hearing i believe construction is
programmed to start in 2023
uh it'll be at least a two-year
construction span so any um
changes at least to the lift bridge
operations probably wouldn't be affected
in this biennium but in future bienniums
would be we'd be looking at that that
staffing but
for about 2021 about two years till that
project begins construction
so we have that in the 10-year plan is
that correct
yes okay so
um all right
so we'll we'll look at that in uh
24 and 25.
yeah we'll probably run into a million
environmental uh
uh programs but that's okay we'll see
what
we'll i know you guys will take care of
it so representative heath you have a
question
yes thank you um stickney avenue
facility um did we finish that project
or what where what's happening there i i
see a lot of zeros
um in that area what page are we on
um so representative heath you might
recall i'm doing the last budget
with the one-time general fund surplus
and we were provided
the dollars to demolish the styx
facility and then our intent was to
surplus the property
because that building is historic
um we were required to market the
building and see if there was any
interest
in someone purchasing the building
and renovating it rather than
demolishing it
and taking it down and through that
process
we did receive one bid
and as is our practice we went to the
city of concord we always provide
municipalities with the first right of
refusal
the city chose to take up their right
or first refusal and so we've been
working through the purchase and sale
agreement with the city of concord
and so at this time we would not be
taking down
the building and we'd be selling it and
with
some of the historic covenants requiring
it to be
renovated um and restored
and then from an operations perspective
um we had been
using the stickney av site um several
agencies were tenants there
and we ourselves were storing materials
there and so
we've been preparing and clearing out
that space
and and one by one agencies have been
consolidating their operations and
finding other locations
for the activities that were going on
there so
eventually the site will be sold and
that's why you'll see some of the items
being zeroed out in the budget
thank you madam chair by may inquire
further about the other two
projects that they were working on
absolutely
um commissioner you had
there were two others i believe
did those did you finish those projects
or were they
delayed as well so the intent
at one point these projects were called
out individually i think in the
governor's phase the budget later it was
consolidated into one line item for
building demolitions
and so we were hoping to move forward
with
potentially um demolishing a number of
our
closed rest area buildings and then also
there was a project to um remove a
building
um in the um the rail yard in west
lebanon
and um unfortunately again with covet 19
as with our capital budget items a lot
of those contracts were put on
hold temporarily because it was
you know there was a lot of concern
around general fund revenue
and um we didn't want to move forward
with any of those items
and should there be significant budget
deficits
but the other items we are starting to
move forward with again at this time
representative murray thank you um
estimated sale price for stickney avenue
so the money will go back into the
highway fund um because that's how the
site was purchased and bill do you want
to i can't recall what the
purchase and sale price was or
yeah the um the bid by the uh
well yeah the the bid that was
subsequently matched by the city was
just
under um a million dollars
okay um could we go back
on page 894
where the money is when you actually
purchase
property or is that part of the
um construction project or
does it go in here yeah representative
um
the the purchase of property is actually
part
of our federal program so you'll see
that as part of
accounting unit 3054 a little bit later
in the budget
and it's class 401 land interest and
that's where
we appropriate the funds you can see
there's 10 million dollars each year for
okay do we have anything else here i
have
still have a couple of questions
but i need to i need to find them in
this
oh i just wanted to say that i love
the material research bureau
if um if any of you have
not ever had an opportunity to go to
this
maybe i'm the only one that loves stuff
like this
but it is a phenomenal
outfit and i just want to
say that it is uh it's something that
needs to go in the highlight of uh
things you need to do
in uh in new hampshire
but i anyhow i just
just want i did make a note to that
effect and uh
i wanted to pass it on okay
if i may madam chair you know we were
very disappointed with covert 19
and we weren't able to have an open
house like we did at the start of the
last legislative session
um to sort of showcase all of the
different aspects of the work at dot
but certainly we're always open to
conducting tours that people want to see
specific facilities or if there's
specific projects you'd like to
go out and take a look at with us in the
field we extend that invitation
often to the members of the public works
committee
but obviously we'd be willing to host
any of you and
show you different aspects of what we do
i think you know the budget can be a
little dry
it's um much better when you see things
um in person
and both our materials and research
facility um
is impressive but also new mechanical
services we talk a lot about the fleet
with this group
we'd be happy to have you tour our
facility and see the condition of some
of the trucks and the type of work that
we're doing each and every day
mickey you have already discussed the
uh changes in uh municipal aid
and so we don't we don't need to
talk about that you'll just make the
changes is that correct
uh i i think i would ask for the
committee to do a vote on that and we do
have a change sheet that's the one i
sent
last night i can also share my screen if
everyone wants to look at that now
and ask the department any questions if
you want on the three accounts that
would be impacted but
i think i would ask for a committee vote
even though it's somewhat technical
oh i yeah i agree so yes why don't you
uh put that up in case somebody had
and i have to be honest i did not see
your email
okay you just want to walk us through
this mickey
uh sure it's up to you if uh you want me
to do it or if you want the department
to do it because they could probably
speak a little bit
more to it but i'll walk through in that
if you have questions for them um
i'll defer so the first uh the first
would be the apportionment a so this is
your highway block grant to
municipalities which is the 12
based on the previous year's
unrestricted road toll and motor vehicle
fees
so based on the house ways and means
revenues
compared to the houses excuse me yeah
the house revenues versus the governor's
revenues
in year one there would actually be an
uptick of twenty five thousand dollars
right here you see the change column in
the middle and then in year two you see
the
the savings so to speak to the highway
fund of four hundred and fifteen
thousand dollars so
this is the only uh item out of these
three on this document that actually
touches highway funds unrestricted
highway funds
and again this this is just to align
the revenues up there's no change in the
formula or how the grants would be
paid out ultimately they still get paid
out
based on the actual revenue received um
when that does come in but
we're just truing up the budgeted
estimates right now
and we pay a year in arrears correct
correct it's it's based on the previous
year's revenue
mary sorry representative heath you have
a question yes please
um for item one um that seems like a
very simple change
do we want to take action on that one at
a time or are we gonna act on these
i think we'll probably act on each item
separately
okay would you like a motion to accept
that would work for me um then i
i move that we um for the department of
transportation we accept the proposed
item one
that they that we have before us with
the change
okay we need 23 as well
and um that's
a change of four hundred and fifteen
thousand
forty four dollars and that's a
loss to the highway fund is that right
okay uh
represent lynn would you call the roll
please
representative lynn would you call the
role on this please
i'm sorry i was muted sorry about that
she left the meeting ah okay all right
all right there we go yes all right
thank you um
representative heath yes
uh i vote uh yes uh bob lynn
representative uh murray murray votes
yes
representative petry petrie of ocs
and representative umberger
representative hamburger votes yes
it's a vote of six uh to zero uh madam
in the affirmative
okay thank you very much so mickey let's
so item two and three are um
restricted revenue accounts based on
road toll so the first is the betterment
account so betterment is uh
three cents off the gas tax less the
block grant that's paid out on that
portion
uh goes into a construction program
the department runs and so on page 907
the betterment accounting unit
i have here class line 400 as the
reduction
i i'll defer to the department if that's
a
not the correct expenditure line to
adjust
for this change but i think in the past
usually we we
would have impact class 400 so in the
first year
there's a reduction of uh nearly six
hundred thousand
four five nine four zero zero eight and
is there any comment from uh
marie or the commissioner
that that class line is uh fine and
where
we know it it's truing up the road total
revenue projection
so we agree with that change
okay uh
do i have a motion to accept oh okay
reps
represent petrie thank you do i have a
second
back in all right
you see none uh representative lin
would you call the role please yes
certainly
um representative turcotte yes
representative heath yes
representative lynn votes yes
representative murray
murray votes yes representative petry
petrievolcies and representative umberg
representative hamburger votes yes all
right so vote of six
and lastly the senate bill 367
account uh on page 909 this is the
4.2 dedicated uh portion of the road
toll
the gas tax that goes to fund those
statutory
um uh established uses so there's a
reduction here relative to block grant
paid on that portion of the road toll as
well as
um the net being the uh
class 400 the construction line done by
and again are there any questions or
comments
sorry just from the department we agree
with that that change again
with that true up um and based on the
law and the the waterfall schedule that
we had presented to you
at our last meeting um it is appropriate
for
for it to come out of the class 400 and
okay um representative murray you have a
question
yes thank you um can you speak to how
this these lower estimates impact the
so these lower estimates would
just reduce the size of our
our program uh potentially the the
amount of paving or
um bridge work that we're able to do um
for both items representative murray um
the reduction in the betterment and the
reduction in
the sb 367 revenue
they both actually impact the betterment
program if you recall
with sb 367 the waterfall is such that
you know we
we have the 12 block grant that comes
off the top and then we have
to pay um the interest on
i-93 we have the state a bridge program
and it's the balance that essentially
flows into the betterment account so
it's the betterment program that is
impacted ultimately by both of these
thank you it's sad to see revenues
okay uh could i have a motion please to
accept the um
capital investment from sb 367
changes murray don't move
thank you do i have a second 30 seconds
all right thank you very much
representative lin would you please call
the role
yes certainly um representative turca
turcotte voces representative heath
heath vote jess representative lynn
votes yes
representative murray murray votes yes
representative petri petri vocias
representative humberger representative
humberger vote
yes all right it's a vote of six to zero
in the affirmative
thank you now if things change
within the next week we may have to
i after
steve lavoy who is you know works with
the collection
side i don't think that
we're going to see much of a change
in the road toll collections over the
next two years
from what's been projected so
uh anyhow thank you mickey for
uh putting that together in marie and
i'm sure that you helped okay
are there any other
questions
okay i i do yes murray
thank you madam chair this is probably
an uber question but again it helps to
have the broader narrative
on page 927 can we speak to
the um 19 million
authorized going down to a million
and the governor's recommended and 103
was spent
can we just get the back story behind
that event
thank you so i i can answer that
representative
um so this is this is the turnpike fund
and in the turnpike fund all the capital
work is included
in the operating budget so this is a
work that was planned
on the central turnpike um
based on the progress of
several of the major projects as well as
the impact to covert
the the spending on what was projected
on one of the capital projects
was not completed in 21 actually that's
going to be
moving um into 22 and 23. so
there's less money needed because these
are non-lapsing
accounts so that money actually
does not lapse it moves forward and
that money will be utilized in the
future on those uh
on the major capital work and actually
this money is probably slated for the
effie everett
might this is the total collection
so i think it might have to do with all
electronic totaling in dover rochester
i was looking at i was looking at the
top of the sheet central new hampshire
turnpike but i agree with you marisa
this is for
all electronic tolling um on on the
spalding trump
okay
is there um anything oh i'm sorry
representative heath
please thank you madam chair mine's more
of a comment
than a question and i feel like
you have come before us and you've done
so much
and i feel like i want to apologize that
we're not
able to help you more um you have so
many needs
and right now just it's such a tough
budget
and i so appreciate all the work and
efforts that you have done to
put forward a balanced budget and i just
know how difficult it is
but please know your work is greatly
appreciated and i feel like i'm always
last time i did the same thing because
we couldn't help you to the extent to
which
you really need the help and at some
point the big huge infusion that you
need
i hopefully when our revenues come back
representative murray thank you i second
what
representative heath was saying and i
also want to say that the
the new connection that the spalding and
route 4 where you take that turn off to
go to
um concord is really fabulous yeah i
only made three mistakes
twice going one's coming back and it
works beautifully and it just it looks
terrific so thank you for
i'm so if i may madam chair you know we
are
very proud of the work that we do at dot
and we understand that
every single person who needs to travel
throughout the state of new hampshire
relies on us to do a good job so
um it has been a tough budget and
revenues obviously have made it
challenging
but we've worked very hard to be you
know conservative
and to really put the brakes on some of
our work
um at a time where revenues were
uncertain and we're pleased that
um as we've been first working with the
governor's office and now with
you on the 22 23 budget that we have
some confidence and can
you move forward this summer
construction season with some of the
projects that we had temporarily
suspended
and we'll continue to advocate the
federal level for as much assistance as
we possibly can get and i just want to
thank the entire team at dot
marie does tremendous work and but all
of our administrators
and directors um you know are timely in
providing her the data and information
that she needs so it's
the team effort and we really thank you
for recognizing um
you know how much uh effort we've put
into this and most importantly the
financial controls that everyone has
been doing their part
okay just one last question i i think
i'm
full of it today um
of your uh personnel
positions how many are unfunded
um so representative we currently don't
have any unfunded positions
um but after your offer at the end of
last meeting um we did go away and talk
about
how beneficial it would be to have that
opportunity
um to put forward on some unfunded
positions
in this budget and then have that
flexibility to be able to
potentially unfund a position
that is in the budget when it becomes
vacant and be able to instead move
forward with one of the
unfunded positions and so i really um
thank you for offering to provide us
with that flexibility
and we've been talking with mickey about
what the appropriate language might be
um to give you a a specific example of
where we might use this
um you know as we move towards
electronic tolling as an example and we
won't need
uh as many toll collection positions
um but we'll be using um easy pass and
we might need assistance in the back
office
so it'd be very helpful for us to put
forward
some new positions um that would be
unfunded at this time
and then you know as the budget would
progress we would be able to
unfund some of the vacated uh toll
collection positions
and instead move forward with an
alternative position that would be much
more
efficient for us and then having to wait
until the position is vacant and go
through a reclassification process
and it would also take some pressure off
the division of personnel who works very
closely with our hr staff in that area
and so if that's still something the
committee is willing to entertain
and we'd be happy to continue working
with mickey on both
language as well as developing that list
of unfunded positions that we would
submit
for consideration absolutely somebody is
ringing my doorbell it's probably a
lba
well commissioner i just want to add i
hope that we can move that forward um
if not today very soon because i think
it's important for you to have that
authority
and i'm pleased that that um we were
able to work on that
that flexibility seems like it'll
provide some um
freedom some efficiency yeah it's really
the efficiency being able to
onboard new individuals much more
quickly
or if we have individuals that want to
transfer laterally you know we're trying
to as we
move towards new technologies and
embrace innovation you're still
find opportunities for the existing
workforce to transition into new roles
i i agree totally and uh that was the
man that was coming to cut my blueberry
bushes
so that i can have some really nice
blueberries next year like i did this
year so
can i ask a basic knowledge question or
a lack of knowledge on my part
um the it's very strict and difficult
for you to move uh you know like in this
case
one position to some you know another
position there it seems to be very very
siloed
was there an historical reason for that
because it just seems to
tie the hands of agencies instead of
giving them a little bit more freedom to
do their work
i just wondered if there's a story where
there was abuse in that regard and
that's why we have these silos now and
is this something that is a longer
i have absolutely no idea representative
murray
um it's at least since uh
2012 when i first joined finance it's
been that way
and um i don't know
uh if uh mickey has any
background on this or or are we just
uh i have nothing really more to offer i
i would probably
defer to the department to be more
experts on the matters of
personnel rules and and everything
involved with that but
um i mean it's something we can explore
more if you'd like to at some point
um that's probably a pretty big
conversation for this stage of the game
you know where we're at with with this
year's budget but um
but yeah i mean there's state the state
personnel rules the division of
personnel
you know has processes and and
everything so
it might uh uh be something to look at
for a uh a bill
in the you know in the future so
representative heath you have a
question madam chair i just want to
agree um as a former employee of the
department of education
and the time involved in um
trying to get on board new positions
um to trade positions to shift them
if it's still the same way um sounds
like it still
is it would be i think something that
i think that would be a division one
area
but it certainly would help folks to
move
okay um mickey have do we still need to
uh approve some uh house bill 2
so we've got the transportation highway
our excuse me um
house bill 2 sections that you could
accept
what's in there now you've you've
received some feedback from some of the
policy committees
we can certainly go through those if you
wanted to you know
accept those as they are right now and
take a vote and get those behind you
while you've got the department here to
answer any questions
as far as any new amendments i don't
have anything drafted but we can
certainly
we talked about the unfunded positions
establishing unfunded positions
there was other talks of perhaps uses of
any excess surplus from this year
that that came up at our last work
session with the department again we
don't have any language on that but
um we've been working behind the scenes
on some things and if that's something
the division wanted to have drafted we
could have that for the next work
session
that's up to you representative where
you want to go for the rest of the this
morning
okay i think that um go ahead and draft
what
what you would indicated and we will
look at all of those at some other time
uh primarily because we have two
new representatives on our committee
and they need to be aware of
the um of the language that's
uh currently in hb2 and
um if we have any questions
we'll reach out to
not only not only dot but
okay i would go ahead reps and marie
i'm sorry i just had one other comment
my neighbor's brother
used to work for d.o.t and he has
nothing but good things to say about his
okay i would like to close by thanking
everyone from d.o.t joining us today
and as has been expressed
this is not an easy budget year
by any stretch of the imagination
and you have done a really great job in
making sure that
[Music]
and i'm i'm just
so pleased it has made our job
a lot easier and um and
i thank all of you for the time and
effort
and that you have put into
putting this budget together and
you know i i have said to the other
commissioners
that if more dollars
become available then uh
the senate will will spread those out
but i'm not sure in the highway fund
that there is going to be additional
dollars unless
they're able to infuse some general fund
dollars into
the the highway fund but really thank
you
all for the great work and if we have
um while we're doing the areas in hb2
if we have questions we'll make sure
that we get in contact with you so
thank you very much and um have
oh wait this is thursday i was gonna say
have a nice weekend everyone's taking
tomorrow off right
okay so uh thank you all and
for the committee we will see you
tomorrow morning at ten o'clock
when we are going to be talking about
the university and the community
colleges
and their and the merger that's proposed
in
hb2 so if
does anyone have any questions or
comments
okay we'll see you tomorrow morning
at uh eight
no no at ten o'clock so
thank you for a great day take care
thank you madam chair